good morning hank it's tuesday my
mustache is back it's a pizza mist
miracle remember not all miracles are
good this video was filmed in the past
because i am scheduled to be away from
my computer and all other electronic
devices for a period of about 72 hours
which will be the longest i have gone
without cyborging myself through
computer power since around 2006
but we're not here to talk about how the
machines have already taken over we're
here to talk about how bad
current me is at predicting what life
eight days from now will look like
but first off go to pizzamist.com and
get your pizza miss gear
all of this amazingness is only
available for the next few days and all
our proceeds go to charity once again
that's petemus.com okay that's the end
of the ad
okay so i am currently living in the
late morning of october 5th
2020 eight days before this video will
be uploaded
and today i'm going to try to predict
what the future you are living in will
look like now eight days is not a hugely
long period of time but nonetheless my
predictions
will be pretty terrible there are some
areas where i can use
modeling and extensive data to predict
what life eight days from now will look
like for instance i can be
fairly confident that on your today it
is unseasonably warm in
indianapolis similarly it is a
reasonably well informed guest to
predict that the number of newly
diagnosed covid cases in the united
states was higher yesterday than it was
a week earlier probably by around 10 to
12 percent
and i can predict about how many people
are gonna buy this pizza john shirt
today probably around 40. although don't
be afraid to
beat that expectation then we get to
places where i have some data but not
enough to make a confident prediction
like what happened in afc wimbledon's
game against swindon town that happened
in your past but my future
i think we might eke out a draw based on
current
form but that's a guess and then we have
guesses based on scheduled events like
for instance i'd know there's a
presidential debate upcoming i suspect
that in your present that's being much
discussed but whatever has happened i
suspect the news of my morning will feel
like the very distant past not like
eight days ago for the record
this morning the main news was that the
president of the united states has been
hospitalized for covid
and many people close to him have
contracted the illness after a series of
indoor maskless gatherings
even though that feels like very big
news to me i suspect that it is not big
news to you because the news cycles are
moving
much faster speaking of which there are
also the
vague predictions that will always be
accurate like i predict that eight days
from now twitter and reddit and facebook
will be absolute dumpster fires that i
will be unable to stop refreshing until
and unless i
physically remove my body from the
internet and i predict those platforms
will continue to recognize that usage
goes up when people feel
uncertainty and fear and so the feeds
that they choose to show us
will increase our feelings of
uncertainty and fear
and i predict that we will feel like
there is cause for alarm and i also
predict that there will
be cause for alarm and we'll all be left
wondering whether the chicken of
algorithms wanting us to be scared so as
to better capture and monetize our
attention
came before or after the egg of our
political social and economic
instability
but what all these predictions have in
common is they say more about the
present where i'm living
than they say about the future where
you're living what's really freaking me
out about the future these days is not
the things i
know i don't know like the afc wimbledon
score for instance what freaks me out
are the
unknown unknowns the things i can't no i
don't know like in november of 2019 i
could never have imagined that afc
wimbledon wouldn't win a single game in
april of 2020
not because they played poorly but
because there was no football
and that is what makes the future really
hard for me to look at right now
so i'm trying not to look at it that
much to be honest with you have any
unknowable
unknowns come to pass in the last eight
days you know better than i do
regardless i hope you're doing okay and
i hope i'm doing
okay too so far away from the internet
hank
i'll see you tomorrow